hey leute hier ist eure mal war eine tat
erzählt er
wolltet ihr schon immer mal wissen wie
es ist wenn ich ein kind habe ich auch
nicht aber gibt's trotzdem
also dranbleiben es wird jetzt erst mal
geschaut
dein zimmer auf mein zimmer wir haben
kein geld für ein zweites mal zu denn
das hätte ich ein letztes mal schau mal
was hab ich denn für heftiges kleid an
komplette überraschung für dich
durchmesser
was gibt s zum abendrot noch reste von
einem schulbrot geschichte erzählen
es war einmal ein mädchen das hat nicht
auf ihre mama gehört und dann ist es
gestorben
ende was ist denn hier los eine richtige
and car to x wanne
ja ich war ganz fleißig bei photoshop
und habe das hier mal so gebastelt was
ihr so um mich von sieht rechts könnt
ihr sehen woran man eine besser kennt
und links geht es zu einem faq wenn ihr
schon immer mal wissen wollte wie ich
auf meine video ideen komme ich möchte
mich natürlich bei jemandem ganz toll
bedanken
hallo wenn euch das video gefallen hat
dann gibt doch einen daumen hoch und
schreibt in die kommentare
kinderbonus russkoje